you see this is how you make a speed
sequel unstoppable now Tony Scott's
directing is kind of a funny thing it
used to be like Top Gun you know normal
and then it became like epilepsy on a
stick you know color is shaking cameras
now I don't know if he cut back on the
whole shaky camera crazy colors epilepsy
thing for this movie all I know is that
for this particular movie it seemed to
work
so UNSTOPABLES the story of a veteran
train conductor Denzel and his really
green training captain james t kirk and
the small problem of an unmanned
brakeless 32-car train carrying
hazardous materials and speeding at 70
miles an hour into town bad day at work
you know when you screw the pooch at
work and your manager just chews you out
slaps you on the wrist gives your
write-up whatever imagine that but
instead of getting chewed up by your
manager a lot of people just die poor
Frankie from Boy Meets World and of
course when news of this runaway train
gets out everyone tries every
harebrained idea to stop it like it's
some little girl in a well in the 80s or
some but unfortunately this train
is kind of like Twilight it's enormous
it has way too much momentum it is an
unstoppable force of destruction in fact
it is unstoppable Twilight so what's up
to our guy's Kirk and Denzel to stop it
now once again apparently the summer
movies need to take notes from the fall
movies I like the characters in this
movie you know a little bit about them
but you don't really know too much about
their past but for this movie in a
strange way it made it easier to put
yourself in their shoes or maybe I'm
just justifying really shallow character
development the movie had its douche
bags it's cool characters it's likable
characters a young hot rod who pretty
much is Kirk and everything he does and
nail-biting intensity I mean when I
watch a movie about a runaway train
that's about to decimate hundreds of
thousands of people that is exactly what
I look for like they read my mind I
would say the Tony Scott movies of the
past decade or even longer this is my
favorite one definitely no I don't want
to look like I'm giving away awesome
tacular but to say it's Tony Scott's
best movie of the past decade or more
and then not give him an awesome tacular
makes it look like the best he can ever
do is not awesome tacular and I'm just
not that douchey so I would say
unstoppable is awesome tacular
it's like speed or imagine the climax of
Batman Begins - the fog that makes you
crazy where they have to stop the train
from reaching Wayne tower imagine that
for about an hour 45 minutes it's pretty
much unstoppable so if there is a movie
to watch this weekend I would say
unstoppable is definitely it and if
you'd like what you've seen here and you
want to see more than click right here
to see more just don't watch skyline you
can watch my review of it
[Music]